you know I am totally on board with the
lore of Avatar The Last Airbender they
do a great job of building a world that
feels real unbelievable characters that
you really care about because they're
well-rounded and likeable but really
really you're telling me I'm supposed to
buy into this into a six legged flying
bison beaver bear that just flies around
in the least aerodynamic way possible
weighs like 3,000 pounds and can still
somehow managed to outmaneuver flaming
cannons fire bolts and lightning well
yeah actually believe it or not it's
entirely possible using evidence from
how things work on the show practically
everything we see done in the bending
world is feasible using basic real-world
scientific principles meaning that the
Avatar isn't just some mythic master of
the martial arts he's also got himself
one heck of a killer science fair
project
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that proves there's no age
limit on a Saturday morning cartoon
addiction so first off can I talk a
little bit more about Appa from the cold
open sure everyone's favorite sky bison
might seem like one of the most
unrealistic elements of Avatar The Last
Airbender but his powers of flight are
indeed possible and I proved it in a
series I did in partnership with
Nickelodeon yeah the Nickelodeon you
know the people who produce the show in
the first place the show is called
factor diction and it's basically film
theory with a bit more science some
live-action experiments going on to
focus on classic Nick shows like hey
Arnold avatar Rugrats and Drake and Josh
you remember about a month ago when I
did the goo lagoon episode of Spongebob
and I gave you a preview of what the
show was gonna be about and you all
pinky swore to me that even though I was
spoiling some of the secrets that you'd
still go and watch the episodes when I
told you so so that Nickelodeon would be
really impressed with me and all of us
theorists and how passionate we are as a
community well now is when I need you
the most now is what I need you to go
click the top line of the description
and binge watch the first three episodes
of Factor niche in one on SpongeBob
when I'm hey Arnold and one on Avatar
and airbending and the realities of
Papa's flight it's available on Facebook
right now but don't worry you don't need
a Facebook account watch that said if
you do happen to have a Facebook account
please do me a favor and leave a comment
saying how excited you are to see me
working with Nickelodeon okay
it's like a dream come true getting to
do something with them and I would love
to do more in order to do that I need to
prove that people liked watching the
show in the first place so thank you so
much in advance for doing that for me it
helps more than you could possibly know
but now onward with a different but very
related episode waterbending to me
Avatar The Last Airbender is one of the
most exciting fictional worlds ever
created a world with four major tribes
the air nomads the earth Kingdom the
Fire Nation and the water tribes within
each group for individuals with the
power to manipulate the given element
air earth
water these are our benders with bending
being one part ancient martial art in
one part naturally given skill however
across time there will always be one
person who can master all four of the
elements that person is the avatar
basically the embodiment of a great
spirit of light who's tasked with
keeping all the elements and balance
when the show starts we meet Aang a 12
year old or a hundred and twelve year
old Airbender who's just been named as
the next avatar he's told that the Fire
Nation with all its firebenders have
started barbecuing the other groups and
now he only has a few mere months to
master all four elements to save the
world no pressure there right and that
was 12 years old the biggest thing I had
to worry about was my complexion
hoo-boy I was a pin bleep at for years
I've wanted to talk about the science
behind some of these abilities with the
recent announcement of the Netflix
avatar remake I finally have myself a
good excuse because the great thing
about the show is its logic sure lots of
what we see on screen is magical but
it's magic that makes sense
highly advanced water benders can
manipulate the human body because you
know the human body has a lot of water
in it advanced earth benders can bend
and warp metal because of the mineral
deposits hidden deep within the ore but
not only does the progression of
abilities featured in the show make
logical sense but they also makes
scientific sense when you stop and look
at what exactly benders can and also
can't do with their respective elements
the magic of it all really just boils
down to each bending type mastering
control over one key scientific
principle so with four types depending I
can theorize about we have between now
and when this new show comes out to make
it through all the science of these cool
abilities so today I'm tackling what is
literally the coolest bending style of
them all waterbending and by coolest I
mean temperature-wise
because we're dealing with ice and
tribes that are located at the Arctic
poles I'm not trying to pass any
judgment here on specific types of
bending even though we know that earth
benders are objectively the best so the
question today how can you water Bend
like Katara simply by using real-world
science yep yep let's get started now
first as we get started on this epic
multi-episode journey let me lampshade a
little bit obviously I'm not claiming
that the powers we see in Avatar The
Last Airbender are real or can be
directly replicated via science the show
clearly conveys bending as an art form
science an elemental manipulation is
done through mastery of the different
martial arts so in that way I'm not
trying to explain away anyone's powers I
instead want to look at the reality of
making water behave like it does on the
show based on the rules that we see on
the show and then talk about the science
that would theoretically make it happen
what forces could make water move around
like that or change to ice or generate a
spontaneous tidal wave you could say
this is all just a theory but why would
you so silly catchphrase to its credit
the show provides a lot of information
about elemental bending and water gets
some of the most solid evidence for
instance the show establishes early on
that celestial forces have a huge impact
on bending ability especially when it
comes to water and fire benders we
learned early in the series that fire
benders have been able to overpower all
the other nations because they siphoned
power off of sozin's comet a fiery comet
that passed by Earth and bestowed its
flaming energy to the fire nation our
hero Aang is forced to train as quickly
as possible to acquire his avatar
abilities because sozin's comet is on
its return trip giving the Fire Nation
so much power that not even the avatar
will be able to stop on similarly for
the Water Tribe we learned that their
powers are strongest during a full moon
the waterbenders draw their power from
the moon and it is nearly full tonight
with Katara specifically noting that
waterbender powers are strongest at
night I've always noticed my
waterbending is stronger at night we
also learned that eclipses have the
opposite effect on benders firebenders
and water benders both completely lose
their abilities when the Sun or moon are
respectively eclipsed just this
information alone gives us key Intel
about the underlying science behind
bending for firebenders it would seem
like solar radiation is playing a key
role in their powers since they lose
those powers when it's blocked but again
that's a theory for another day for
water benders a lunar eclipse is gonna
block their powers entirely
now the moon doesn't emit any sort of
solar radiation per se but it does exert
another major force on earth gravity
gravity from the moon is in fact what
makes all water on Earth bend in the
first place in the form of ocean tides
and currents all caused by water
sloshing around on the face of the earth
it's pulled literally bent outward by
the gravity of the Moon on one side and
then sloshes back on the far side of the
earth effectively creating these bulges
on either side of the world where the
high tides are all the water in the
middle is being sucked out creating low
tides and the show absolutely knows that
this connection exists and it does a
really good job of reflecting it as a
basic property of water bending from the
earliest episodes Aang and Katara
practice push and pull bending creating
tides it's literally the first
waterbending move that bang learns
they're making the moon's tides to
create waves and they use this basic
skill a lot to wash people out to sea or
unbe to commandeer all starting with the
fundamental idea that tides are
controlled by the gravity of the Moon so
that's cool and all but I hear you
asking what about this or this or this
well as good of a start as gravity as we
know that things are gonna start to get
a bit more complicated as we dip our
toes into advanced water bending from
the water whipped water shield ice
bullet and good ol puddle to the face
this level of precision makes our
gravity explanation feel a bit laughable
I laugh at gravity all the time gravity
so scientifically there has to be
something else layered on here that's
gonna allow benders to control water
more directly the good news for all us
aspiring avatars is that it's
theoretically possible to bend water not
with Tai Chi or hand waving or various
dances but with the powers of
electromagnetism now most of us are
generally aware that water is
electrically conductive but not
necessarily for the reasons that we
expect it's not the water itself that's
electrically conductive it's actually
the salts that exist within the water
regardless though it's the reason that
you don't go swimming in a lightning
storm or
your hair in a bathtub it's because the
salts within the water are super
conductive and lightning or electricity
flowing from your wall socket loves to
run through it and as a result we'll
also run through you if you happen to be
swimming in it but electrically charging
that water isn't gonna do anything to
make it move just makes it more
dangerous
that's why bending also requires the
magnet part of electromagnetism if
someone were to ask you if water's
magnetic most of us would say no right
doesn't contain any sort of iron or
metal doesn't really seem to do anything
when I wave my magnet at it that's not
entirely correct the truth is that water
is actually diamagnetic meaning that any
magnetic field whether positively or
negatively charged is actually gonna
repel water so if you put a magnet near
some water you'll see the water is being
very slightly bent by the magnet pushed
away from the magnetic field now in this
experiment we have two syringes that are
filled with equal amounts of water set
to a string that allow them to freely
rotate right so if we present one of the
sides with a magnetic field what we
should see is the water start to bend
away from those magnets in turn the
syringes will start to spin away from
that magnetic field this is because of
the diamagnetic properties of water
where water isn't magnetic it actually
rejects magnetism and thus wants to move
away from it and that's exactly what we
see happening right here right where the
syringes were level 2 the camera at a
certain point now you start to see them
moving slowly away rotating away from
the magnetic field that I'm holding them
to on this one side and now if we
present it in the opposite direction you
can see that now the syringes are moving
the opposite way this is to prove that
it is indeed the magnetic field that's
causing this rotation and nothing else
this is quite literally water bending at
a microscopic level where the magnetic
fields are pushing the atoms of the
water away in the syringe so
theoretically speaking a waterbender
could do the exact same thing by
creating electromagnetic fields that are
strong enough they can actually push the
water away from themselves creating all
the
cool awesome moves that they see them do
in the show science and magic and
bending now if you're a physicist this
explanation is gonna be pretty
simplistic but for our purposes it
actually explains a lot of things that
we see play out in the series
waterbenders rarely touch the water as
they're bending it which makes sense
because the water is always being
repelled from them and the intricate
curves and shapes that you see a-making
are coming from the electrical field
that's applied to the water water
molecules generally have a small
negative electric charge so by creating
small electrical fields that are also
negative because like charges repel each
other
waterbenders could theoretically
redirect the flow of the water midstream
creating swirls Spears bubbles whatever
they wanted which is exactly what we see
them creating with more and more
precision over the course of the show
early water bending moves focus on
establishing an electromagnetic field
for simple shapes but once the bender
learned to control the fields with
greater precision it's only a matter of
time before their water spearing it up
with the best of them we also know that
we're specifically dealing with
electromagnetism and not simply
magnetism from an unlikely source
the fire nation just like water and
firebenders are related by their
reliance on objects in outer space
they're also linked by their
manipulation of electricity and charged
particles in the season 1 episode the
storm we see our first instance of
lightning redirection as uncle Iroh
saves Zuko's boat from an electrical
strike we find out later that he learned
this ability by studying waterbending
philosophy ie studying electromagnetic
fields that could be created in the air
to repel charged lightning particles and
bend them away from their targets the
technique i am about to teach you is one
i learned by studying the waterbenders I
mean he says it's kind of like Tai Chi s
philosophy but we all know the truth we
go on to see lots of other firebenders
use this technique to either redirect or
create lightning from their hands but
it's all based on the principle of
generating an electrical current and
directing it through the air in theory
in film theory this same principle
actually explains some of the whack year
and more McCobb aspects of waterbending
- including vine bending which we see in
the foggy swamp tribe human bending and
water purification plans and people are
made of a huge amount of
all of which can be manipulated using
electromagnetic fields create a strong
enough field and you can bend a vine by
bending all the water inside of it by
the same token you can bend a person if
all the water in their organs and
bloodstream are being pulled in one
direction we see a select few water
benders even cause people to lose
consciousness using water bending
presumably by preventing water
what's carrying all the blood from
getting to the brain when it comes to
other obscure water bending techniques
like purifying water you know that
although water is polar a lot of its
contaminants aren't oils and dirts are
all made of carbon meaning they won't do
much of anything in an electromagnetic
field so water benders are able to pull
the water away from the impurities deep
polluting it and making it drinkable so
electromagnetic manipulation explains a
lot of water bending techniques but it
still leaves us with one big missing
piece that I can't just make melt away
phase shifts the most advanced water
bending techniques involve significant
phase shifting between water's states of
matter particularly liquid and solid ice
to water and vice versa the ice sled the
ice ramp taggers drills even missed
stepping which involves stepping on tiny
little ice rods they are all valid
techniques of water benders not purely
explained by electromagnetic fields or
are they the techniques that we've
covered involve manipulating the motion
of large groups of water molecules
puddles lakes ocean waves but what if we
wanted to manipulate motion on a smaller
scale in chemistry and physics you learn
about thermodynamics and you find out
that on the molecular scale the idea of
temperature is really a measure of
motion molecules are moving fast
well we perceive that as hot that bowl
of soup you got there is no different
chemically whether it's hot or cold it's
just that the molecules in your hot soup
are moving a lot and in your cold soup
they're just kind of sluggish the same
goes with ice and water liquid water
molecules move and flow and wiggle and
have a good old water molecule time but
ice molecules are locked together in a
crystal lattice structure just like you
see in snowflakes there's still a tiny
bit of movement there like they can
kinda wiggle around in their framework
but the motion isn't much less than in a
liquid or gas phase we know that
advanced water benders have the ability
to turn water from liquid ice - what are
they really doing in those instances
well what a super small scale there
relating water molecules to slow their
individual movements or in physics terms
their kinetic energy as they lose
movement they lose energy becoming
colder if the bender is able to slow
down the individual molecules enough
they'll start to lock together into that
crystal structure we call ice the key is
the use of those same electromagnetic
fields to slow the movement of
individual molecules to lock them in
place so there you have it if we want to
be water benders all that's really
standing in our way is the ability to
create concentrated magnetic fields at
will by waving our arms around and then
having that ability tied to an
overwhelming reliance on the
gravitational forces generated by the
moon no sweat right maybe one of the
other bending abilities will be a little
easier for us to master I mean even
Avatar Roku said that waterbending was
especially challenging for him and like
I said if you want more avatar science
right now and you still haven't done it
please go and check out my episode of
Factor Nixon on oppas airbending flight
and then go watch the one on SpongeBob's
underwater campfires you can have fire
under water in fact I show it in the
episode and then finally round it off
with a discussion of hey Arnold's pigeon
man all three of those episodes are
available right now with more on the way
every Tuesday for the next couple of
weeks link is down below and like I said
you watching that series really helps me
out
heck you might want to do more with me
which would be really cool working
alongside the people who created my
childhood is really awesome so thank you
for your support there link is where the
arrows are pointing down below in the
description and speaking of more
episodes make sure that you ring the
bell to subscribe to film theory because
you can bet that I'll be talking about
more bending soon the science behind
earth bending in particular is very very
cool and again totally rooted in real
life science ah get it routed it so if
you want to see that episode make sure
you hit that subscribe button and let me
know down in the comments that you are
here for the avatar Ness now you'll
excuse me October is starting to get
close you got to start stockpiling some
spooky over here